welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the finale of gen
V the short but sweet episode has a lot
going on with it and the ending
especially teases some major things Eric
kpy and the creative team have been
talking about the Sentry for a while and
how it's going to TI to the overall Arc
before the release of episode 7 they
teased that this series would go
directly into the boys season 4 and that
that show would then run into genv
season 2 so we will definitely be seeing
these characters returning and the way
they leave things off teases a lot for
the future first though just a quick
word from our sponsors this video is
sponsored by Opera GX the special
version of the Opera browser built
specifically for gamers they've teamed
up with genv v from the world of the
boys on a world Cross promo tour where
they're bringing you lots of exclusive
content from the show that you
definitely want to check out not only
are they hosting the fictitious social
media platform for V International but
they're also giving you lots of behind
the scen stuff with genv and what could
be coming in the boys season 4 now Opera
GX is different because it lets you
customize your brows it be exactly how
you want it they also have the brand new
genv modern GX store that comes with a
number of different functionalities it
has background music keyboard sounds
opening and closing tab sounds themes
and colors of the browser mods dedicated
wallpaper and arrange of features and
mods to explore and create now inside
Opera GX you also have access to V that
is V's International social media site
dedicated to the world of the boys it
simulates our characters on the series
user based on the pl of the show so you
can get exclusive content only available
to Opera users all you have to do is
click the three dots at the bottom of
your sidebar and enable V under the
messenger section from here you can also
access loads of other social media sites
like Discord twitch Twitter Tik Tok
Instagram and WhatsApp with one click
now we all know that switching browser
says it it's a pain but Opera GX they
actually come with an import tool that
allows you to bring everything across
this includes your browsing history
bookmarks and cookies and it's also
compatible with every Google Chrome
extension all you have to do to get it
is click my link in the description
below and download Opa GX today watch
genv on Prime video and also use Opera
GX to get exclusive boys content that's
Opera GX which you get by clicking my
link in the description completely free
highly recommend it so go check that out
now thanks now we up in the aftermath of
shed's death with Kate dealing with the
influx of thoughts coming in from what's
just happened interestingly Sam's the
only one who doesn't really react to it
and I couldn't hear his voice over
during any of this bit as we've seen man
loves sticking his hand at people like
their actual puppet and he's dealt out
way worse deaths than what's happened
here it also explains why he's so
willing to join Cade and I also feel
like shed's death will be pinned on the
others too we'll talk about why this is
a good thing for homelander later on but
shed's death completely fractures the
group Sam and Kate decide to go and free
the woods while the other side try and
stop their rampage now from here we cut
to the seven Tower where we can see the
damage from outsides further along in
the repairs Andre is still there looking
over his dad but a bit of a gut punch
comes in what's revealed by the doctor
assessing that every time he uses his
powers it causes a tear in his brain
matter Andre is being subjected to the
exact same fate this is all of course
caused by his father who made the choice
to inject his son with compound V he was
so focused on his son doing what he
couldn't that he forced him down a path
of trying to get into the seven polarity
was obsessed with being its quote
unquote first black member but this was
taken by a train so he never got to
fulfill his dream also I know every time
that gets brought up people obviously
talk about black noir and how he was
really the first black member in the
group however we saw what Edgar's
reaction to him wanting to be masked in
his youth was and I'm guessing that they
come completely hit his race I don't
think it's inconsistency I think it just
shows what V is like and even with Black
Panther in real life we saw how he was
promoted internationally when it came
down to Disney so yeah just a side
tangent there but polar's failure made
him Force his own son to live his life
and the pair both now have the same
condition Andre says how am I looking
like you made a steal which calls back
to the saying that the pair have had
throughout the season he now wants his
son to wear the costume and admits to
playing a with the woods the costume is
very much a curse now though with on ra
Powers also slowly killing him his dad
still pushes him to use them though and
tells him to stay on the straight and
narrow and take care of his family this
is pretty much him telling his son to
stay quiet and though he'll do the right
thing he doesn't really want him to be
someone that rocks the boat in the end
Andre Rebels against this and it causes
him to get locked up which is also kind
of a fate that befalls all the other
good characters now V have their own
problems as well and we could to Ashley
and the pr team at the godu campus all
this negative press has caused
applications to drop and they now want
to catapult a student into the seven to
buy some good publicity pulling out
Andre's profile we see some really
interesting stuff in it including the
risks that he might rebel against his
dad they also have his additional skills
as being that he can do a British accent
and chance pedma who plays him holds du
citizenship he was born in the US but he
moved to Southampton as a kid and he's
just got a sort of sort of British
accent in real life but was full of good
times it's full of laughter it's full of
love and I can definitely say that in my
experience it's just been it's been a
family yeah it's been a family now the
name Andre andison also carries the
alliteration that a lot of comic book
characters have they argue over his skin
color and it's what I imagine lots of
corporate boards to be like even though
they push the ideas of being inclusive
and diverse now we C to the W and see
several of the students trapped in their
cells all of which are unleash by Kate
really get some messed up murders on
screen with some ripping out a guy named
Bob's face and K getting another to eat
his own hands we see the students fully
unleashing their abilities throughout
and catch the fire suit that got teased
that earlier in the series man hasn't
seen the sun since 2012 all the way back
when gagam style was released he's also
dripping with sweat too since his power
centers around him heating up going back
to his cell Sam sees a vision of his
brother much in the same way his
brother's Visions used to haunt him
earlier in the season he sort of acts
like Sam's conscience throughout the end
But ultimately Sam turns away from his
better judgment what I love about the
show is that you can kind of see things
from his side too as he's being locked
up and experimented on for just being
himself all of these soups have been
rejected and oppressed and the next
obvious steps for them to cause an
uprising mental health plays a very big
part in this season and whether it's
with eating disorders depression bipolar
you know lots of things going on it's
clear that the students struggle with
having the the powers that they do now
we could have campus grounds where we
see Rufus recording a reaction to
Desperado avoiding attacking soups the
woods prisoners move through the campus
killing humans and metaphorically I
thought it acted like a school shooting
spree I think there's clear Illusions to
how security footage from them is been
presented with it being one of the
darkest things that both shows have ever
tackled it's pretty graphic with Kate
even getting the social media manager to
use an explosive on himself it's
revealed that he's undercover working
for the woods and we see him busting out
the same Sonic device that the guards
had earlier in the season Sonic was
shown to be powerful enough to stop
homelander and it manages to stop the Su
encounters by the Kate way more powerful
and she catches him off guard leaning to
the Fatal live stream that gets more
publicity for the massacre back in the
boardroom we see them debating whether
to enlist Maverick with him talking
about how he could be a pervert like his
dad as we know translucent hung out
literally around bathrooms and we know
that Maverick's hanging out the back of
Sloan anyway in the theater Society we
see Adam Burke watching an audition this
is a monologue from his film dawn of the
seven with it being something that he
loves due to his own ego attacked by Sam
he ends up fleeing and I'm going to be
honest mate I was sweating for him
thinking Burke might not make the Burke
cut I he say by I'm arriving and Sam
ends up going off on one about how this
is what normal looks like when he's been
treated the way he has been Sam says
Emma wants what's best for her and that
she's just doing things so that people
like her got to disagree man and when
she was going on the run to save Sam she
truly seemed like she gave it all up but
the popularity definitely ended up
costing her however this is easily the
lowest point she's been at now at this
point she shrinks down showing that her
size is more to do with her mood than
what she eats in vomit clearly having to
make herself sick to shrink caused a lot
of emotional turmoil but she and her
mother wrongly assumed that it was tied
to food instead this shows that it's
actually linked with how she is mentally
and this low Point has made her go to a
low point we'll talk about how this
could impact the ending but it
definitely feels like it changes the
Dynamics now because of this Emma's
clothes don't fit her but she could get
some new ones at the heavy spoilers
merch store right now we're selling
T-shirts inspired by Loki Ahsoka and
even a d say like Theory time so
definitely go below the video to check
them all out we've also just launched a
versus top with two of the most iconic
villains in pop culture which is now
part of our classic movie breakdown
brand all the money helps video like
this get made and huge thank you to
everyone who's bought one I love you now
K continues to try and recruit Andre and
we see she offers to make Sam a soulless
killer he takes her up on this offer to
make his brother go away and in the end
he stops hating himself he says goodbye
to the personification of Luke and
allows Kate to make him feel nothing at
this point he's truly lost and I felt
like it was such a tragic Arc for the
character I actually wonder if he could
end up being in the seven and they might
make him take over the position of black
noir I think the whole twist they do
with him is too well known to make it
shocking in the show and they could end
up using Sam instead so far V have kept
his death under wraps and they might
even end up keeping it Hush Hush so
things don't get exposed when you think
about it Luke was injected with Sam's
blood to power him up to be level with
homelander and Sam coming in could be a
sort of similar situation now across the
campus we see his things get locked down
and the bars drop in place this is
something we've had teas throughout the
show with even the first episode
highlighting this makeshift prison Sonic
alarms are also played across the campus
and we see Marie running under a
painting of The Seven this is on the
ceiling like the cinee chapel with the
art style being similar to how it is in
the comics cut to Ashley which is when
we hear B shouting I can hear you Ashley
now you open this door I swear to God
I'm going to tell everyone what you and
I did in the bathroom at the Pediatric
kider fundraiser they also did something
similar at the dawn of the seven
premiere which continued the whole
ripping out her hair thing this was
actually a n of the comics with the py
CEO in that doing the same thing when
the blame fell on them now the sonics
are destroyed by a Sonic soup who lets
out a scream like banshe from the X-Men
at this point Ashley asks for homelander
and a helicopter to be called which sets
up what happens as the episode ramps up
Ashley offers Maria position in the
seven and also the chance for her to
have a meeting with her sister after her
parents' death she was shoved off to Red
River and has desperately been trying to
get back to her sister the only other
goal has been getting into the seven and
here she has those two things offered on
a platter however as with all things
vought it's just a superficial status
symbol rather than being something that
has any depth just in the same way that
the school's being a fraud the seven
itself is also this too now outside Kate
commands that the helicopter be taken
down and we see Andre still doing the
right thing even though it's costing him
it makes me wonder whether the V is
going to cause all the soups to go like
this as we had the brain thing happening
with Kate as well when she was using her
Powers Al massive shout outs to our
editor map for pointing out the
aesthetic of this episode is very much
like the X-Men the name genv was of
course a playoff the Gen X movie and
they made gulin School in the comics
something like the one for gifted
youngsters beyond that though Kate and
Maria are like Magneto and Professor Rex
with their ideologies lining up almost
exactly Kate wants to wipe out all of
humanity and this is because they try to
commit genocide Maria on the other hand
doesn't want to do that but she also
doesn't really have any out and out
Solutions commanding Maverick to take
Kate out we see her going to to to with
a major test with golden boy she ended
up running away but here she has to
prove that she's actually a hero now I
love the way she starts trying to give a
motivational talk and yeah man so many
comic book movies to evolve into this in
the third act can't you like find the
real you or something just to see it fa
out this is hilarious and and she's the
one who has to dig inside herself to
make Maverick's blood appear taking him
out the school start starts to crumble
while Jordan tries to save the elite I'm
kind of surprised that they downside
with the Guardians at the end but it
clearly shows how much Homeland is in
control that shut of him in the seven
Towers almost making it seem like he's
giving approval to the story because his
propaganda wings now controlling the
narrative the pr teams probably scared
that the truth will come out and this is
why the Guardians are locked up in a vot
facility we will talk about it later on
in the video but this move was clearly
done for a reason after rejecting Kate's
call on Sam go head-to-head which leads
to the former using a stun stick on him
this somewhat has a sense of irony to it
as it's what weapons would have been
used on him when he was in the woods now
we then go to a face off between Kate
and Marie and I kind of feel bad for the
predicament they're in you are not a
person you're a product to them a freak
and to be honest Kate is kind of right V
going to use her to get what they want
and if she tries to stand up for herself
they they're not going to care they just
see Maria as a commodity and in the end
even though she helps she still ends up
betrayed channeling her powers she saves
the higher ups once more and ends up
blowing off Kate's arm to stop her using
her powers now the episode ends with
homelander arriving and you can totally
feel the entire tone
[Music]
shift speaking of tone shifting I love
how the music does too with a heroic
entrance kind of droning out now what he
says here is extremely important and
even though she's respectful he sees
soup UNP crime as being indefensible do
you like attacking your own kind to him
the real wars between superhuman and
human and this plays his hand for what
his real plan is I want to talk about
some comic spoilers in just a bit but
I'll save that for its own section in
case you want to duck out that also
involves what happens with the butcher
scene but they're clearly heading into a
similar Direction now as for the
Guardians the news is running with the
story that they were behind the murder
spree with even Emma being robbed into
it too new Guardians have been elected
with Kate and Sam now being pushed as
Heroes what Homeland has really got
though is two complete Psychopaths who
can easily be accepted into the public
narrative however what they really are
though is people who can be controlled
which symbolically has been shown in the
characters themselves Kate's pushup
Powers allow her to somewhat puppet
someone and Sam himself sees people like
that looking at this subtext this was
obviously done on purpose to add a sense
of irony to what's about to happen
homelander is no doubt going to control
them and he's got two extremely powerful
soups now operating under him one comes
with strength the other comes with the
brain and these two people are going to
cause a lot of issues now there's also
the possibility that even if things are
brought to the surface that no one's
going to believe the good guys you think
they're going to believe a black girl
and a by gender Asian soup overv as for
the gang they're hul up in a hospital
room with no doors Windows nice little
detail on the gowns themselves is that
they have these on them cuz cuz you have
V now what this does show though is that
V still has them under control so it's
not like something that we haven't
experienced in the show we also see
Maurice survive the blast cuz we know
soups have super strength and even
Stormfront could survive getting lasered
in a chest like this be because of this
line don't be a [__] laser my [__]
tits as for where they are I actually
think this is Elmyra which has being
teased throughout the show so far we've
seen agage Grove in the woods but this
is the one place that hasn't been shown
to us this is obviously a brand new
location we haven't been to before and
with Elara getting dropped in yeah I
think that's where this is now there
will obviously be doors but they'll be
flush with the wall and this is so that
the Guardians can be kept prisoner I
actually think right I think Emma's
going to be how they escape as her
powers go beyond being activated when
she's sick or eats too much just in the
same way Ant-Man kickstarted endgame I
think that Emma will be the one who
helps to solve all of this her breaking
into the woods shows she has the
capabilities to break facilities like
this and only shedy suspected her
involvement which I'm guessing these
have overlooked as for what they're
there for I don't think that Vault will
want them around anytime soon and
instead they might be used to juice up
other soups just like how Sam was either
way though this is clearly a v facility
so it makes sense that they would want
to keep a close eye on them kind of
reminds me of what Ma was kept in as
well and yeah they're not being killed
off yet they're just being kept under
God who knows they might even test the
virus on them as we don't know what
Vic's done with it and they could be
altering and and trying to weaponize it
now the episode ends with a major mid
credit scene that sees Billy butcher
then discovering the woods though last
week Victoria took the canister of the
virus Billy could reverse engineer it
due to the corpse that we know was left
there he was given less than two years
to live at the end of season 3 with him
swearing to take Victorian human down
thus him going there could be getting
the virus too which may be where things
all head off to now to the sounds of
kids in America we close out wondering
what's going to happen next but but I
feel like I have a pretty fair idea full
swall is ahead for the comic book so if
you don't know what happens in it then
please turn off now anyway homelander is
clearly putting his people in place to
take over everything which is what ends
up playing out in the source material at
herogasm he hires a woman of the night
to distract the V CEO and goes to give a
speech telling them to mount up however
just before delivering it the CEO
returns having sused out what his true
plan was burned by this homelander still
continues his cause and he begins to get
the soup to all side with his Rebellion
going to the White House he ends up
killing the president who at this point
is victtor Newman vicet Infiltrate The
White House as the vice president but
once the man in charge was killed he
then got the position I think that this
is something that will happen with
Victoria and that she'll take over from
Singa when something no out happens to
him the homelander at this point sits in
the Oval Office with Victor's head which
is when butcher is sending to take him
out at this point we get the reveal that
black noir is a clone of him and he
kills homelander before butcher finishes
him off butcher then goes on to kill all
the boys except Huey and he attempts to
wipe out every soup through using a
radio frequency that detonates V now
personally I think they'll condense
these plot lines into one to make it so
that Victoria is killed by homelander
and that butcher then unes the virus
this will take out not only him but also
the soups across the world resetting the
Power Balance and taking it away from V
this would lead to a lot of soup deaths
and potentially someone like Marie can
help control the disease in the end of
the comics butcher did fail with his
plan though and thus Huey and Annie were
able to have a life together still
though I think going in this direction
mean they can bring all these elements
together into one cohesive plot I love
how all these strands are fitting
together and the Cameo by butcher tops
it off perfectly this was actually
teased to us last week with a line a man
who works for me one of your fellow
country although I doubt you travel in
the same circles has the same rage so
yeah nice way to bring things full
circle from that now home ler being
brought into shows how he's s to handle
a situation and that he truly aligns
with Kate's ideals to wipe Humanity out
I think it could really make things ramp
up into something spectacular and I
can't wait to see where they go with it
as for my thoughts on the season this
was a really strong show that was way
better than my expectations for it were
I thought this was going to be you know
some CW kind of spin off that water
things down but it really elevated the
boys for me in a way that I thought it
never could seeing this world from a
teenager perspective add did a lot and
there was so many great twists and turns
throughout every episode was better than
the last and it kept growing in quality
each and every week I do feel like the
ending of the finale like that last
couple of scenes was kind of just very
short and ideally I would have liked to
have seen just a bit more I personally
hate when stuff just randomly cuts to
Black without having a proper ending and
yeah I think that final scene could have
been a bit longer even if I was enjoying
seeing homelander show up it's a nitpick
in what's been a really strong show
though and I hope you've also enjoyed
our coverage of it obviously I'd love to
hear your comments on it too so make
sure you drop them below and again huge
thank you for rocking with me for the
last how many week five weeks was it I
think my matters are very good on that
but they dropped those first three
episodes on day one that's just throw my
Ms off and and it's reasons like that
why I stuck to being a YouTuber now
please drop a like on the video as well
and if you want to support the channel
as a member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button we get
early access to videos every week and it
Go such a long way to helping us out
we've also just teamed up with arrow
video I absolutely love buying their
films and if you do too yeah we've got a
discount code below you're going to get
10% off their website so just a random
shout out to them H but yeah thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul you've been the best watch
something else and I'll see you next
time you take care peace